today we are trying Valentine's Day
candy said you'd be my exciting oh good
I don't know it's mysterious candy the
little heart-shaped chocolates that are
in a box that you can't tell what they
are some of them are probably just
chocolate maybe a caramel some of them
I'm really bad like that's for sure I
know for some reason some of these
chocolates have coconut in them
oh just like the chalky heart yeah you
thinking of I like knowing what I'm
getting myself into
rather than you gonna take this chance
look at what would you say that is right
there nut hot dog that is from this
that's cute
this nice chocolate I wanted to get
nicer but then it gets more scary I will
never look at chocolate the same way
again the smell isn't so cold
quite desirable there's be smell that
kind of fella just to this oh my god Oh
what is that what is that boo
it's an onion last nothing I was like I
smell well are any single additive I
just don't know what we did to deserve
this I mean it reminds you of a turd so
like normal talk though you know like
hot chocolate from Starbucks that's what
it smells like what the [ __ ] well Rob Oh
coconut it's coconut is this raisin or
bacon Oh baby
actually I like it it's very sweet
outside of the bacon and salty so it
goes really well yeah buy it
I wouldn't buy like whole boxes I love
bacon with eggs no reason the [ __ ] with
chocolate just eat it it's been around
for a long long time for a recent don't
put meat in the chocolate it's that big
Bacon's okay I mean I might be eating
bacon that I cook for myself cuz I'm
single the hearts she I'll eat that
talking yeah take that candy any day now
don't make it for your girlfriend or
your mom are you there you don't think I
don't don't make it for anybody
[Music]